but it's a trick no it's much more than  that whosoever be he worthy shall haveth  up whatever man it's a trick please be  my guest come on really yeah plant  you've had a tough week we won't hold it  against you if you can't get it up  judgment please start by all means never  one to shrink from an honest challenge  it's physics all right so what if I lift  it I then rule Asgard yes of course i  will be reinstituting prima nocta  Birkbeck  [Music]  are you on my team just represent pull  all right let's go come on cap  hmm Widow oh no that's not a question I  need answered all difference to the man  who wouldn't be king but it's rigged you  bet your ass Dave he said a bad language  word you tell everyone about the head of  imprinted right like a security code  whosoever is carrying Thor's  fingerprints is I think the literal  translation yes that's uh it's a very  very interesting theory I have a simpler  one you're all not worthy  you